make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
okay so picking up with heroes in crisis
part for God we're kind of behind uh we
need to get caught up like I let
everybody in the comic book YouTube
scene get ahead of me now I have to
crush them all with my uploads okay so
getting into heroes in crisis part four
so this is alright this is kind of cool
because one of the things to bear in
mind again kind of getting back into
this this here is a crisis thing this is
designed to show the side of the
superheroes that we don't see right so
like it's really familiar it's really
similar like Civil War clothes you guys
who never read Marvel Civil War course
was a big calamity the superheroes
versus superheroes but what made it cool
was you saw like small little moments
well they were different heroes like t
rare who were like I cannot afford to be
a college kid and a superhero at the
same time with my identity out there in
the world and if I have to choose one
I'll choose to go to college and so like
they would quit and so it was like these
small little things and that's what's
cool about heroes in crisis initially
this picks up with like tempest who's
basically drunk in a bar and just kind
of rambling on and going on about
nonsense it's not designed to really say
like he's a doer like a huge shock or
anything like that it's designed to show
these heroes at their worst when they're
at their lowest points because what this
is designed to do what the whole concept
of hero in crisis is designed to do is
to humanize the heroes even more than
they already are
to basically say like whenever you go
and buy a Batman book all you see is
Batman fighting one villain after
another but what happens between the
panel's like what happens between these
issues what's tim is doing what's
superman doing what's Batman doing what
are they doing between these conflicts
how are they coping with like all these
major events that are going on and so on
and so forth that's what is designed to
focus on and that's why it's so cool
because what we end up doing here is we
switch over to Booster Gold now remember
Booster Gold was a person who is
basically on the scene when like the
whole event of really like the deaths of
all these superheroes went on during
sanctuary you know he woke up early
Quinn was there but as far as
everybody's aware they believed that
Booster Gold was the one to do it and so
what he ends up doing is basically
taking this kind of lasso test where one
woman puts the lasso around his hands
and where he basically divulges
everything he saw and what he says
really kind of it's really cool for tom
kean to do this because it kind of
catches this up but what he says is
basically like I was there I made a
confession just like everybody else and
then like all hell broke loose and
that's basically it like as far as I
know Harley Quinn was the one who did it
because like I came out there and like
everybody was dead Harley Quinn had this
bleeding mallet and then she started
hitting me with it and then I woke up
later on and that's it that's all he
really knows I mean that's one of the
things to bear in mind is that when it
comes to Booster Gold he's kind of the
perfect culprit to blame if you're the
person who
committed all these acts these remember
boosters entire superhero antics are
shrouded in fraud he's a guy from the
future who dreamed of being a superhero
after beating it being basically a
nobody he stole a whole bunch of
technology for a museum he traveled back
to the present day and said I'm a hero
from the future once that was found out
he was just kind of like okay whatever
this guy's not really much of a hero at
all but he still kind of went along and
did various hero antics but he was just
kind of like the class clown the
goofball the one who's more inclined to
screw things up than to get things right
and so if you're a person who's gonna
commit a crime no one sees what it is
that you've done and Booster Gold
happens to be there he's a perfect guy
to blame and so this is when the plot
thickens because what we do here is we
switch over to - Lois Lane speaking with
Superman you know talking to Clark Kent
and what she basically reveals here is
that she's been getting information
she's basically be getting the video
files these confessions that people have
been making they've been sent directly
to her now she of course is kind of
operating under the assumption that if
they've been sent to her they've been
sent to other people but remember Lois
Lane is a reporter and so for her it's
the story that really seems to count and
that's one of the kind of things that
that honking really draws here is he
almost kind of draws this idea there for
Lois Lane it's the story first and then
everything else second but it's not
necessarily that way because the case
she makes here is someone's gonna drop
this scoop my source gave me these files
the implication seems to be that
somebody else or other people have the
files or or could get the files besides
her source or at the very least her
source got the files in such a way to
where they could be leaked to the public
and so her idea is we have to make this
story public and we have to make it fast
because if we don't somebody else will
do it before I do and they won't be
unbiased don't put a slant on it and
it'll be things like are superheroes
trustworthy are superheroes good guys
you know they'll do it in such a way to
where it has a political leaning where I
as Lois Lane can do it in the most non
slant way possible as that's why it's
one of the cool things that kind of goes
on here is because it's the question of
does Lois Lane have a moral obligation
to publish the story given its very
nature in the fact that if somebody else
does it they'll do it in and what
Capilla could be a negative way it's
possible they could do it in a positive
way but remember when it comes to the
superheroes in DC Comics there's a lot
of negative slant sources and they're
not inherently bad and as like society
as a whole views them as a negative but
it's one of these things where the news
exists to sell itself and so if the news
can be sold in such a way to where it
could be done in a negative fashion and
people will eat it up more likely than
they would be if it were done in a
positive fashion then that's what they
will do and so again it's kind of a
funny scenario because and what you end
up doing is picking up with Batgirl in
Harley Quinn
and the two of them literally start
immediately coming to blows now there's
a couple reasons for this one because
it's Harley Quinn and Batgirl and two
because Harley Quinn's basically on the
run here that seems to be the indication
throughout this whole story and she's
essentially like fleeing for life
because for those who have been
investigating this whole thing and those
who are looking past Booster Gold is the
immediate suspect that makes Harley
Quinn public enemy number one it makes
her the number one suspect so she was
quite literally caught with blood on her
hands with the whole thing that was
going on in sanctuary and she'll with
Batgirl showing up here of course the
kind of discussions look you know I'm
not really here to bust you or anything
like I'm here to help you I'm here to
try to figure out what's going on so on
and so forth and so the two of them kind
of kind of calmed down and sort of Hagen
and go from there but it's kind of
interesting here because what that sums
up doing is is sort of switching over to
Blue Beetle and this is kind of a cool
little thing here because remember Blue
Beetle and Booster Gold they're two peas
in a pod they're the best of friends and
one of the things that really gets
talked about here with Blue Beetle is is
that exact thing when Ted Kord is going
through here and he's talking about
these different concepts one of the
things that he hits on is his friendship
with Booster Gold and that's why he says
like I put Booster Gold first like I
trust Booster Gold if he says he didn't
do it then I believe him but it's a very
important thing here because as he goes
through and kind of talks he talked
about the nature of what it means to be
a hero right like you're effectively
surrounded by death and suffering all
the time that's the nature of what it
means to be a superhero is that heroes
do various heroes die all the time and
that's why the story is so cool is
because DC Comics on the whole largely
focuses on like the popular heroes the
cool kids table that's basically DC you
don't really see what goes on in like
the band geek table or like the comic
book nerd table you don't really see
what goes on on those little tables over
there but we're kind of left to assume
that they're heroes they do things and
some stuff happens and they sort of go
about their business and they go to bed
and then all I kind of good stuff
you don't really hear their story you
don't see which one of them died you
don't see which one of them loose
friends you never really learn about
that with Blue Beetle here he's kind of
like that happens all the time like in
that table over there they lost four or
five guys in the last three weeks you
look at that table over there well
they've lost 10 guys in the last year
but you never hear that story but when
he says he's a superhero he's sitting at
the tables just like everybody else
surrounded by all these different tables
of all these different heroes some come
and some go and it's just the nature of
the beast and it's kind of like how do
you get past that how do you learn to
cope with it and the response he gives
is it's just the way it goes it's just
kind of it's just the nature of the
beast how this whole thing happens is
that's why he says when things get hard
and things get tough Booster Gold is the
one that he goes to and that's why it's
kind of cool because for all the benefit
that cord into
does in terms of providing a kind of
financial back-end to the building of
sanctuary to a lot of different things
that go on at the end of the day Booster
Gold and and really Blue Beetle are
still kind of considered to be outliers
they're heroes but they're not really
heroes you know what I mean like they're
not really part of the Justice League
like through there but when people say
oh my god we got to get ahold of the
Justice League nobody thinks of Blue
Beetle
nobody things our Booster Gold they're
just kind of heroes who were there and
like these serve a purpose occasionally
even in the real world reading comic
books is kind of a non running joke the
most significant moment in Ted kord's
life was getting shot in the head like I
mean it's just one of those things that
you kind of get with when it comes to
comics isn't as sort of the guys who
were down there and so that's why things
get sort of crazy is because what
happens here is we basically pick up
with Superman when he's speaking
directly with Batman and Wonder Woman
now remember they're the ones who made
sanctuary right like sanctuary uses the
technology of Superman in terms of the
Vale available technologies and the
fortress of solitude they can create
like Holograms illusions different
things like that so it uses that
technology with regards to creating like
Holograms and so on coping mechanisms
different things like that it uses the
ingenuity and the money of Batman in
terms of how to pull it all together and
of course it's all based on the empathy
of Wonder Woman and her ability to like
understand other people's pain so
between the Trinity they have
effectively built sanctuary and so it
makes sense that with things popping off
the three of them are talking but
Superman shows up here in says look
there's something that I have to make
you guys aware of and then the question
is what they know the response is Lois
Lane is gonna go live with a story about
sanctuary
she has all the the various data logs
now of course Batman's response is
that's not possible they should all be
gone and deleted and remember that makes
sense because what you're talking about
here are confessions of superheroes and
no one knows what they're gonna say when
Wonder Woman did her confession she
talked about killing Maxwell Lord when
Superman did his confession he talked
about dying when Batman at his
confession he talked about having his
back broken by Bane these are the
innermost thoughts of people at set of
various superheroes being recorded on
these data logs things they would never
share with the world things they don't
want anybody else to know their deepest
darkest desires their deepest darkest
confessions all are being made on these
data log tapes and that's why they're
supposed to be deleted almost right off
the bat so that nobody can ever get
their hands on them but what seems to
have happened here is by one means or
another someone got their hands on all
these different video tapes and when the
question is asked when is Lois going
live with the story Superman says well
that's why I'm telling you it went live
33 seconds ago and so it's just like wow
so so basically like all this
information is now
they're about the superhero community
all these confessions are now out there
it's literally throwing everything out
there into the world and taking all the
deepest darkest secrets especially with
Batman when bad Isis answers like I've
had a desire to kill heroes before I
have I've had a desire to eliminate them
to destroy them to wipe them off the
face of the earth but I can't do that
because I go it goes against everything
I stand for like what those confessions
being being made and thrown out there
they're available for the world to see
we're just going to fundamentally change
how the world views superheroes but with
that being said guys we're gonna bring
this video to an end if you are new here
two comments explain make sure you guys
at the sub button to become part of the
robb core if you guys enjoyed this video
make sure you drop a like and I will
catch you all later purse
[Music]